hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar freeze-drying
solutions for your lab i am michelle
ashton of blabbers tune I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by lab roots and sponsored by lab
Congo for more information on our
sponsor please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor you and anytime
you want during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the spy window click
on the arrows at the top right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
trouble seeing or hearing presentations
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
and education credits please click on
the continuing education credits tab at
the top right of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
I'd like to now introduce our presenters
Meghan Zimmerman product managers and
Jenni's from senior application
specialists at lab console corporation
to learn more about our speakers please
visit the speaker tab at the top of the
presentation window our speakers will
now begin their presentations
Thank You Michelle and thank you to
everyone for joining us today we'll be
talking about freeze drying solutions
for your lab we'll start by discussing a
general overview of the freeze drying
process followed by how to flow to
freeze dryer to meet your needs then
I'll pass things off to Jenny and she'll
talk about how to develop a protocol
freeze during challenging samples and
troubleshooting first we'll start by
discussing some common terms you'll hear
when talking about freeze drying freeze
drying is the process of removing
moisture from a frozen product using a
vacuum but another term you might hear
is why optimization which is another
word for freeze drying that is derived
from the Greek word solvent loving my
awful ice samples are easily rehydrated
making it a great process for sample
preparation because you can easily
resuspend your samples sublimation is
also a virgil here when talking about
freeze drain this is the process and
free string in which solvents pass
directly from the solid phase to the gas
phase
giving freeze-dried samples such great
preservation properties because you are
bypassing the liquid phase the rate at
which sublimation occurs is dependent on
temperature and pressure
this graph shows what's happening to
your sample when you freeze dry for
sublimation to occur you need to have a
cold enough temperature and a deep
enough vacuum for your sample to go from
a solid to a gas if either of these
things doesn't occur the sample will
actually evaporate and not get the
preservation properties that you would
get with sublimation
this makes pressure and temperature
critical components of freeze drying
when freeze drying is important to cool
the material below its triple point
which is shown on the graph the
temperature the triple point is the
highest temperature at which the solid
and liquid phases of the material can
coexist being below this point ensures
that sublimation rather than evaporation
will occur
next we'll talk about the requirements
you need for successful freeze drying
process
first requirement of freeze-drying is
that you have a free frozen sample
before you start your run when you put
your frozen sample on the freeze dryer
it will be subject to melting until the
appropriate vacuum level is established
you may see this melting occur with
older vacuum pumps or pumps that aren't
working well because it will take longer
for that vacuum to pull down having a
vacuum pump
in good working order is extremely
important for the success of your
freeze-dried sample the second
requirement of freeze drying is that you
have a collector that is 15 to 20
degrees colder than the samples freezing
point in order to trap the vapor coming
off your sample by next by nature water
molecules from your samples will want to
move to the coldest spot in the system
which is the collector coil this natural
migration of water molecules is called
cryo pumping
the third requirement for freeze-drying
is having a deep vacuum with the minimum
requirement of 0.002 millibars this is
necessary because the vacuum pump
establishes negative pressure forcing
free-flowing water molecules that have
left the sample by sublimation to
evacuate from the environment around the
sample and travel to the collector coil
the last requirement for freeze drying
is having energy in the form of heat
while not obvious to a lot of people the
lay application process is essentially a
heat transfer process for example with
blast freeze drawings the flask is
hanging at room temperature and the
ambient heat in the room is what's
driving the process in general the more
heat you're able to apply to your
samples the faster your own will go
however not all samples can take the
same amount of heat input if you add too
much heat to certain samples you could
cause your samples to no
these images are showing the difference
between uncontrolled heat and controlled
heat with uncontrolled heat the flask is
receiving ambient heat from the air in
the room making it hard to control for
samples in the pharmaceutical industry
or production samples
people will typically use a tray dryer
so they can apply controlled heat to
their sample
when freeze-drying there are three
stages that are carved first is the pre
freezing stage where you start with a
completely frozen sample this is
followed by primary and then secondary
draining from many laboratories there
isn't much difference between these two
stages but for pharmaceuticals or more
sophisticated at freeze drying runs
there's a distinct difference this graph
shows the data of a freeze drying run
throughout the three stages of the
process the blue line represents the
shelf temperature while the green line
represents the temperature of the sample
the graph begins by showing the freezing
of the products from the sample
temperature matches the shelf
temperature freezing of the sample has
occurred this stage is then held for a
while to ensure the entire sample is
completely frozen after the hold you see
the shelf temperatures start to climb in
primary drying however the sample
temperature no longer correlates to the
rise in the shelf temperature this is
because the sample is undergoing
evaporative cooling which suppresses the
temperature this is also what allows you
to add heat to your sample during
primary drying with the addition of this
heat you are increasing the rate of
sublimation and shortening your run
times primary drying continues into your
shelf temperature and sample temperature
needs for most laboratories that are
planning to resuspend their sample this
is the point when they would typically
end the run with their samples
containing about seven to eight percent
moisture however for end-users who are
preparing your samples for long term
preservation it will continue to run
into secondary drying
secondary drying is for water molecules
that are bound to a simpler release with
the additional heat in this last stage
you are able to drive those sounds water
molecules out of your sample leaving
behind about two percent moisture
for more sophisticated freeze-drying you
can send your samples off to companies
or they'll watch the freeze drying
process under a microscope they can then
tell you your samples triple point and
what amount of heat input would be good
for your runs in general most labs will
just guesstimate the heat input
fine-tuning their process to develop an
optimized application run
you
now let's talk through each of the three
stages of freeze-drying in a little more
detail in the pre freezing stage if
you're freezing your sample in a flap
you'll want to make sure you're freezing
your sample in a way that gives you the
greatest chance for efficiency during
the run the first example on the Left
shows sub-freezing which is keeping your
sample in a flat surface and is not a
good way to freeze your sample example
in the middle is called plant freezing
where you keep your sample at an angle
while it freezes by doing this you're
increasing the surface area of the
sample which helps reduce your overall
run time the example on the right shale
freezing is the most optimal way to
freeze your sample especially when
you're working with large volumes which
shelf raising does is roll the samples
while it's freezing in a very cold
solution to create a thin coating over
the entire surface of the plaque this
gives you the largest surface area and
reduces the amount of sample the water
molecules have to move through during
freeze drying
once your sample is frozen and you start
your freeze dryer you'll begin primary
drain as you can see in the picture
there's so much about bored of cooling
happening during this step that you will
get frost build up on the outside of
your flask this is a good indication
that your freeze drying process is going
well if you see the frost start to melt
as well as your sample this is
indicating that there's a problem with
your run at this point you are no longer
freeze drying and your sample is
undergoing evaporation
when we are able to control heat input
in primary drawing the temperature
sample as that plays an important role
in your run while some samples can take
a lot of heat other samples don't do
well with heat inputs the example shown
is from a paper where they studied the
effects of freeze drying the same sample
at different temperatures the example on
the bottom left shows the result of a
collapsed cake a cake is what you call
the remaining product after you freeze
dry a sample with this run the sample
melted and underwent evaporation instead
of sublimation when the shelf
temperature was set at minus 10 degrees
Celsius and the product was at minus 15
degrees Celsius the example on the
bottom right shows a result of a
partially collapsed cake with this run
they adjusted their shelf temperature to
minus 15 degrees Celsius with the last
example on the top right they again
adjusted their shelf temperature to
minus 20 degrees Celsius with a product
temperature of minus 25 degrees Celsius
and how to finish product with an
excellent cake you can see that even
though none of these runs had a
difference of more than 5 degrees
Celsius from one to the other there was
still a very big difference in how the
final product turned out this is why you
will have to fine-tune your process to
develop a protocol that will give you
the best cakes unless you plan to send
your samples off to be tested after
primary drying is complete you move into
secondary drains where you're releasing
the remaining water molecules that are
bound to the sample in order to complete
secondary drain you need a freeze dryer
that has shelves so you can Plus apply
additional heat to your sample and get
the moisture content down to about 2%
for long-term storage of your samples
you will want to complete secondary
drain and you'll also want to stopper or
seal your samples under a vacuum by
stopper in your samples under vacuum you
avoid exposing your samples to the
moisture in the air when you open the
door another way to achieve long-term
storage is to flame seal your samples
and ampules before the vacuum is release
next I'm going to talk about selecting a
free Strayer that meets the needs of
your lab the first thing you'll want to
think about is who all will be using the
freeze dryer is this purchase just for
your lab or multiple groups be using the
freeze dryer find out what kind of
samples each person plans to use for the
unit looking at the types of solvents
and assets that make up their samples
also determine who will be responsible
for maintenance such as cleaning the
coils and performing oil changes in the
vacuum pump this will help to keep your
freeze dryer and vacuum pump and optimum
working condition choosing the right
materials for your freeze dryer is
important when making your selection
many solvents youth's and samples can
attack plastic and rubber components
which can cause vacuum leaks over time
because of this it's important that you
know what kind of solvents and acids
everyone will be using because you'll
want to make sure the samples will be
compatible the materials of the freeze
dryer
other than knowing what kinds of
solvents you'll be using you will also
want to determine the collector
temperature you need keeping in mind
that the temperature should be 15 to 20
degrees colder than the freezing point
of your samples free strayer's typically
come in collector temperatures as minus
50 minus 84 and minus 105 degrees
Celsius you also need to determine the
collector size of your freeze dryer
freeze trainers are described by their
eyes holding capacity so if you're
looking at a four and a half liter
freeze dryer that means it can hold four
and a half liters of ice before needing
to be defrosted this does not mean that
you can put four and a half liters of
sample on the freeze dryer but instead
you'd be able to put about half of that
volume on there to accommodate all the
vapors that will come off your samples
when you start your run the next thing
you need to determine is the type of
vacuum pump you means freeze drying
requires that the pump be able to reach
100 microns with the displacement of at
least 98 liters per minute when
selecting your freeze dryer you'll also
need to consider the accessories you'll
need besides offering flask and serum
bottles
we also offer items like - Brax and
micro plate holders with micro plate
since you're working with such small
volume of samples it's very easy for
that sample to start melting quickly
with our micro plate holder you can
place your micro plate on the holder
while you're freezing your sample and
keep it on there during your run to help
keep the sample frozen while your vacuum
is cooling down
another thing to consider when selecting
a freeze dryer is the coil design with
our internal coil design we are able to
provide the coldest possible
temperatures and are superior and
capturing the solvents coming off of
samples compared to an external coil
design that is on the outside of the
collector
additional things to keep in mind when
selecting a freeze dryer what kind of
controls does your freeze trailer need
what do you need to get the appropriate
data and results mere runs do you need
your freeze dryer to meet cGMP standards
do you need a freeze dryer with shelves
to pre freeze your samples when you're
controlling your freeze dryer what kind
of software and programming do you need
how are you accessing your data with our
liar works
operating system you'll be able to
download your data to a USB flash drive
or use an Ethernet connection to send
your run data straight to your computer
through a one-way connection
we also offer remote notification with
the ability to configure the types of
alerts that are sent to your email
since freeze-drying runs can sometime
last four days leaving you wondering how
your samples are doing while you're away
from the lab you can have alerts sent to
your phone showing you the parameters of
the run giving you peace of mind a
vacuum control valve is another
important feature to have in your freeze
dryer by being able to set the vacuum
level you're able to speed your runtime
of certain solvents many people think if
they pull the deepest vacuum it will
feed their runs if that is the case
having your sample set at about 0.2
millibar is actually the most efficient
vacuum setting
and point detection is another feature
to consider if your freeze-drying in
slaps oftentimes it can be difficult to
tell if your sample is done which leads
people to sometimes take their samples
off too soon only to realize the run
wasn't completely and causing them to
start the run over or they are leaving
their samples on for much longer than
they really need just to ensure their
sample is finished wasting time and
energy the freeze dryer is using our
endpoint detection helps you avoid both
of these outcomes by alerting you to
when your samples have achieved the
level of dryness that you've set now I'm
going to pass things over to Jenny we're
still discuss developing a protocol
right Thank You Megan we're going to be
discussing how to work with your freeze
dryer to make the most out of it
now that you know how to choose your
freeze dryer and what drying chambers
you want we can discuss how to move
forward with developing your protocols
in a typical freeze dry cycle you would
want to pre freeze your sample whether
it be on yourself or in a flask so
that's the first determining factor if
your freeze drying on controlled heated
shelves and controlled refrigerated
shelves then you would set up your main
drying system if your freeze drying in
flask you would attach your frozen flask
to a port and let the freeze dryer do
its job
to optimize your program and your
process you never want to overfill your
containers what will happen is you could
potentially break your flask or it will
take a very long time to freeze for your
free shred process to go then surface
area is better on your trays as well as
in your flask is Maegan discussed pre
freezing on a slant or in a shell are
the best ways to do it you want to
consider your pump requirement if you
don't want to do a lot of maintenance a
dry or scroll pump would be your best
option
you do need to make sure that you have a
specific minimum requirement for your
pump in order for it to do freeze dry
work never oversize or undersized your
vacuum pump
the pre free step is the most important
step in freeze-drying you don't want to
end up with a sample that will melt
immediately on your freeze dryer because
you did that pre strike correctly or
long enough the greater surface area the
better when freeze drying your samples
there are two ways to pre-freeze a
sample you can do that quickly or you
can do it slowly the rate of your pre
freezing will affect the ice crystal
size of your samples faster pre freezing
will create smaller ice crystals where a
controlled cooling will create larger
ice crystals that are typically quicker
to freeze dry
once your sample is completely frozen
you will move on to primary drawings you
want to add a little bit of heat
transfer during this step but not melt
the sample so this is a very important
step in your freeze dry process make
sure during the run that your samples
are not melting and you're not seeing
any bubbling in your flask or on your
tray dryer if you do start seeing melt
back you can brief refreeze your sample
or lower the shelves temperature if
you're running on shelves
you also need to look at your room
conditions a warm room could also create
melt BAM you want your room about
ambient temperature or 22 degrees
Celsius for the best conditions if the
room is too small it could get too hot
based on your vacuum pump running as
well as your collector running so a
medium to large-sized room would be
better you don't want the freeze dryer
and direct Sun if it's under a window
the heat caused from the Sun could also
cause melt back to your samples
and if your freezer is located in
another room or another building make
sure you are insulating those samples on
the walk to get to the freeze dryer
some samples could require additives if
the samples are freeze sensitive you
might want to add a Lyle protectant if
you are worried about losing your active
ingredient you may want to use a keeper
solvent this will all be dependent on
your specific sample and needs to be
thought about prior to the freeze dry
process
the GMP is another thing to keep in mind
when you're purchasing a freeze dryer
according to cgmp regulations our freeze
dryers can be used as you can modify
them to your cgmp requirements most
standard equipment are flexible have
flexibility for you to modify this in
your lab based on your needs what we can
provide for you our materials of
construction the test reports that are
done on your specific freeze dryer that
we've done in-house we can offer manuals
videos and documents we also offer IQ OQ
for you to check those processes on your
own
and PQ can be done by an outside
consulting through
there are many challenging samples that
are difficult to be free strides
one would be tert-butyl alcohol the end
product is not going to be a powder it
will come out more of a gummy mass at
the bottom of the glass this is very
normal and other samples may turn out
like this as well
another challenge would be to freeze-dry
alcohols methanol and ethanol have very
low freezing points which make it
difficult to keep frozen as well as
finding a collector temperature that
will work for your needs these alcohols
must be dilute
about 10 percent or less in order for
them to freeze dry correctly
DMSO as well as BMS tend to attack
rubber and plastic components so these
components may be replaced over time
sugars and salts tend to lower the
eutectic temperature of your sample
which may require a cascade or minus 84
degree model and a hepa filter would be
useful in line to protect your vacuum
pump from any particulates coming
through
soil samples also tend to migrate
towards the pump once they become dry so
a HEPA filter is recommended for soil
samples if you're running whole samples
it's best to homogenize those samples or
at a minimum poke holes in those samples
to allow the vapors to leave
when you're running a freeze dryer
there's a couple things that could
happen the first one is that the samples
won't stay frozen during the process so
you do need to look to make sure that
your freeze dryer is the correct model
and that you do have the temperature
differential between the frozen samples
and your collector temperature if there
are small samples or in plastic vials
that could also cause the melt back
during the run or if there's too high of
an alcohol content in them they may not
pre freeze correctly also you want to
watch your vacuum pressure to make sure
that your vacuum is at a good level
if samples are being pulled out by the
vacuum you can use filter paper or
parafilm as long as there's holes poked
into the sample to allow for the vapors
to leave and if samples are taking too
long to lyall eyes your shelf
temperature may be too cold your sample
might be too thick or there may not be
enough headspace in the vials
once you're running you do want to
monitor your vacuum level if you don't
have a low enough vacuum level there
could be a couple reasons you may have
cracks in your gasket there might be
dirt or debris on your gasket or you
might even need to just do an oil change
in your on your oil pump so these are
all things that you want to take a look
at before running a sample to make sure
that you're going to get optimal
processes
if your final product looks different
each time this might be normal depending
again on your sample different samples
will free stripes differently and it
could be the outcome of your room
temperature the purity of your solvents
as well as the percent of active
ingredient from sample to sample if you
are worried about a cake versus powder
what you want to look at is what
solvents are being used what the
temperature is prior to putting that
solvent on the freeze dryer and also
p-a-t-h shifts during the process
if you are using a hybrid pump or a
rotary vane pump oil changes are very
important and must be done
a scroll pump is an oil-free pump
however that will also require some
maintenance maintenance to do an oil
change you do just want to follow the
manufacturers recommendation on how to
do an oil change and make sure you're
using the correct oil for your pump a
hybrid pump will take a synthetic oil
if you don't do I'll change 'as this
could be the outcome of your pump and at
this point unfortunately the pump cannot
be repaired because it is beyond that
point
if possible you want to open your gas
ballast after each run by opening your
gas ballast to number two and running
the system under vacuum for about 15
minutes you're able to purge any
contaminants out of the oil of the pump
and help the pump run longer
that concludes this webinar if you have
any questions we would be happy to
answer them
Thank You Megan and Jenny for your
informative presentations we will now
start a live Q&A portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is so my
current vacuum pump work with a lab
Congo freeze dryer
that's a really great question so when
we test our products we obviously test
them with the Edwards and vacuu brand
vacuum humps that we offer so we can
always guarantee that those products
will work with our freeze dryers but
what we tell our customers with other
freeze dryers or other vacuum pumps I
should say and is that the minimum
requirement to use our benchtop freeze
dryers is a displacement of ninety eight
liters per minute and now with our
larger units of consoles with a stop
ring or a bulk trade dryer on top that
number goes up to one hundred and sixty
three liters per minute so really it's
just checking with the technical
specifications of the vacuum pump you
currently have
thank you all right your next question
is how can I feel under vacuum without
buying stop urn tray dryer
with our mini separate tray dryer you
are able to stop her off of port you can
also stopper under a gas so a steel
torch flame which works on ampule those
are the two best ways to do it without
the stopper in tray dryer keep in mind
that the stopper in tray dryer will
allow you to pre freeze your samples as
well as do heating and then stop burning
all automatically the other two options
will be more manual and in the mini
supreme chamber as well as if you do the
flame torching you will have to pre
freeze those samples prior to putting
them on the freeze dryer but they're two
great alternative to sending the extra
money on a separate tray dryer
right thank you your next question is
how does end zone endpoint detection
work
with our end zone end point detection
like we talked about in the webinars the
whole idea behind it is to alert you
when your freeze dry samples in a flock
are dry and so the way that it's doing
that is the end zone kit comes with two
vacuum sensors one goes into an empty
port on your manifold the other goes
into a port on the top of your sample
and when the end point has been reached
what what it's doing is comparing the
vacuum level of that empty valve to the
vacuum level of your sample so when
those are even that's when your system
knows that your sample is dry to the
level that you've specified
I want to once again thank Megan and
jetties before we go I'd also like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their questions questions we do
not have time for today are those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information provided at the
time of registration
we would like to thank labyrinth and our
sponsor lab không có for underwriting
today's educational webcast bobrucz will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye
you